what is the difference
between a dependent and an
independent sample and why is it
important to know the difference
i will answer these questions in
this video if you would like to read the topics from
this video again
simply take a look at our book
statistics made equal to the
you can find the link in the video description i
would say let's just start with
an example let's say you want to
find out whether vacation has an influence
on the stress level of people to
find out that you have created a small
online questionnaire on date up
de with which you can ask
you measure the stress level of people with the
questionnaire you now ask people before
and after their vacation about their
stress level now there are two
possibilities possibility one you ask
people before they go on vacation
and ask other people after
they come back from vacation  case
you would have an independent stitch  try
because the people you asked before the holiday
have
nothing to do with the people you asked about the holiday
the second possibility would be
the people you interviewed before they go on
holiday and then ask the
same people after their holiday in
this case  you would then have a
dependent sample the measured values
are always in pairs,
so if the people have
nothing to do with each other you have an
independent sample if
the people you interviewed before and after are
the same and the
measured values ​​are therefore available in pairs you have
one  dependent sample
you therefore have a dependent sample if you interview one and the
same person at two points in time
, once before a certain
event and once after a certain
event with dependent
samples, the march values ​​are used, i.e. a pair
before the pairs result, for example,
from mass repetition at  of
course it doesn't have to be for the same people  There is usually
a before-and-after relationship that is to be
examined.
A dependent sample is also available
if you want to check, for example, stop
a new type of baseball bat has an
influence on the result of a baseball
game and the same people
once with the old and once with the
new bat  lets play then
the measured values ​​are also in pairs before each
player has used both stegers and
there would therefore be two measured values ​​from each player
and it does not
even have to be about the same people
if you want to find out, for example,
stop in a relationship between men
and women women
do more gardening than men you would also have a
dependent group you would
have two measured values ​​that always
belong together in pairs always a
woman and a man and the last point of
course it doesn’t have to be
about people you could also
investigate whether a  lubricants have an
effect on the  downtimes of
machines then you would have
measured values ​​from the machines with the
old and with the new lubricant
the evidence is available so that enough
for the dependent random samples and we
go to the independent random samples
in the case of independent the samples come
from two or more
different groups  For example
, the group of men and the
group of women are
asked about their income in independent samples.
In this case, a person
from one sample cannot be assigned to a person
from the other sample.
Of course, there can be more in
independent and dependent samples
give as two groups or
samples it is
important that in the case of the independent
sample the individual groups
or samples have
nothing to do with each other and in
the case of the dependent sample one respondent
occurs in all groups depending
on whether your data comes from a
dependent  or come from an independent
sample you must
first
use different hypotheses are your data independent
, for example, the perpetrator is used for
independent samples or
a variance analysis without mesz
repetition are your data dependent
, for example, the perpetrator is for
dependent samples or a variant
analysis with measure  repetition used
but don't be afraid data tab will help you
to find the right hypothesis test how to do
that i will show you now
visitor simply data tempi and copy
your data in this table
then select this tab
statements in a questionnaire asked for
salary gender and location
now you want to investigate whether
the gender has an influence on the
salary then you just click
on gender and it will
automatically calculate an offender for independent
random samples you will get the
results nicely presented and the data
tab will even help you both
interpretations
should the vo  If the
requirements are not met
you can also simply calculate the match
if you held
it automatically calculates an analysis of variance
so it automatically recognizes
that it is probably an
independent sample
what if you have a dependent
sample you just get the
data in the data tab  let's say a
variable means before and after if
you then trick the variable before after
the date up automatically calculates
a perpetrator for dependent samples
how does the fact know that there is a
dependent sample
usually a series is one person and
if you now two
if you want metric variables then go pay gap assume that
it is a dependent sample if
this is not the case
you just have to click here and the test will
calculate the independent standing cake so
as you can see there is quite simply with
data tab i would  say just try it
yourself
i hope you enjoyed the video  please and
see you next time